okay so we got Episode five the king of
Omashu and this is a weird one this one
was really odd all the the basic story
if you don't remember is the three kids
they travel to this um the city that
seems to be filled with earthbenders and
it sort of shows how the city functions
again the city's awesome they have this
really cool city that has all these
slides that transport everything that
they need the earthbending can get the
stuff up but then the need to send it
back down so they use these slides and
of course the kids use it for what most
kids we use it for slides um and well
that's so there's some weird stuff in
this one like for example they need to
sneak into this place and they don't
want them to know that he's the avatar
I'm not entirely sure why but so they
have to disguise him as an old man all
right well that's already strange you
know he has the high pitched voice but
get show whatever haha uh they get in
and they find this really kooky King uh
which is a cool idea sometimes they
really have fun with it um but he's just
so strange and I usually love strange
characters but this guy is so odd um and
what they choose to focus on is really
odd you know maybe that's it maybe it's
not even really the character it's just
what they choose to focus on like he'll
say a line and then like he'll eat some
lettuce and they'll really focus on him
eating the lettuce it like squinting his
eye or something I'm like why is that
your way of showing he's weird you've
already done that fine um so he's sort
of the King figures out who this kid is
and he has him go through these
challenges in order to get his friends
back um he puts this ring on the friends
which is like this crystal that keeps
growing and growing until it consumes
them and if you can get through the
challenges in time he'll let them go if
you watch Deep Space nine you can know
they're getting it from that but oh my
that's so geeky but anyway maybe same
idea you know perfectly possible uh and
the whole idea of the challenge is I
guess sort of is a good idea all the
challenges had sort of like a trick to
it or wasn't what you expected um you
know like if I there's even one where
you know this old guy the old king he
has these two soldiers come out he says
you can choose any of the men in front
of you to fight to fight against for the
final challenge and the kid the avatar
thinks he's gonna fool the old man and
chooses him the old man and then the old
man at you reveals he's this
unbelievably strong incredible
earthbender and you know they have the
great big fight so I sort of like that
like a trick on top of a trick but I
guess the purpose was just to show him
to always think out of the box cool you
know all right um it'll be interesting
to see if that actually comes back to
whether that's relevant but this
definitely seems sort of like a side
episode um again what I enjoy the most
about is just the just the creativity of
the city and the idea of the slides
though I don't know how this old guy I'm
giving nothing away by this but this
doesn't Mary seen the episode the old
guy the king is his best friend Aang's
best friend when he was younger and it's
so friggin obvious but they sort of they
play like a mystery but I mean I think
even little kids would be like yeah we
know come on um and uh and the other
thing is what what kid what person would
not put together to go along these
slides and ride them like slides it's a
great scene yeah when they finally do it
and they whatever some of the packages
are riding behind them and gonna hurt
them accidentally if they squash into
him I mean so that there's a lot of fun
stuff when there's this thing with this
cabbage guy that that's cute um but it's
like you know you know you points a kid
like he's a mad genius it's like well
who didn't you know maybe that's the
joke maybe the joke is actually he was
like a mad genius it's like anyone could
put this together maybe that's the joke
I don't know but need to say it was an
odd episode there's nothing with the
prints in it there was nothing really
furthering the story you didn't learn
too much about the characters uh again
you just sort of learned that the same
kid like the literally the only reason
they traveled to this place is to enjoy
the slides and that's just it's kind of
a fun charm about him that you know they
should be discovering all these
mysteries about him or they should you
know be getting guitarra to the the
witch m'god you know the the way to go
this or South Pole north pole I forget
one of the poles the North Pole that's
right because she's gonna learn from
Santa how to waterbend but instead
they're just going these slides so cute
you know so it's sort of a Kevin weak
excuse to show off these places but you
know it's fun enough and it's obviously
just sort of a diversion episode um and
that's always what sucks what do you
have to do something like this not that
out of a lot of people do this
but um you know when you had to go
through at the zone episode you had to
see well this one was filler and it
could be shallow just more with this
episode and I know shows need filler a
you know I understand that uh so you
know I'm not gonna be okay challenge me
more it's just it's part of it
especially being a kid show you need the
one that had the filler I wish the
comedy was a little better since the
last one was so funny um of course this
is the one where my wife walks in you
know I'm just eating lunch on so I'm
just putting on this Avatar show okay
and she says so this is supposed to be
really good right and everyone loves I'm
like yeah yeah it's really good and
imagine you're coming into this and you
see that for the first time would you be
hooked into the show which would be like
oh yeah this looks like a real real
great thing it's like no really it's
it's it's really good so um so maybe
you'll watch another episode I don't
know but um yeah so it just sort of a
subpar episode but again that's as to be
expected I hate talking that way you
know Legos it's not up to my standards
but
you know that's just how shows are gonna
be there's gonna be some there just
everyday shows you know and not much to
him but you need those breathers as well
so um that's about it see you for the
next one